[Music]
on this saturday night overwhelmed and
understaffed
they're just so maxed out
that people aren't getting the help
that they need the collapse in emergency
departments across the country monkey
pox crisis point i have decided that the
global monkey box outbreak represents
a public health emergency of
international concern why the world
health organization was split on the
declaration as the outbreak spreads in
70 countries plus preparing for the
pope's visit he's not going to erase
what happened to me all the damage that
these schools did to me the struggle to
find forgiveness for what happened at
canada's residential schools and a
childhood dream comes true we have two
police people here one's a lady one's a
guy following through on a lifelong plan
to become a police officer
[Music]
global national with bara nasser
reporting tonight tracy tong
good evening and thank you for joining
us health care professionals are
painting a grim picture tonight
overwhelmed overworked and sick staff
are having to contend with a surge in
patients and that's led to overcrowding
closures and staggering wait times at
hospitals right across the country and
with canada's covet 19 numbers on the
upswing there are fears things will only
get worse more on that in a moment but
we begin tonight with the story of an
ontario family who shared their
nightmare hospital visit with our mike
trolley
eleven-year-old macy's journey through
ontario's health system reads like a
cautionary tale her first visit to the
er lasted 12 hours they send us home
with no pain medication no splint
nothing and her arm is like four times
the size at her follow-up visit two days
later she learned her elbow was in fact
broken and she was sent to the hospital
for sick kids for another 12 hours in
the waiting room they gave her a bed but
when she went for x-rays they gave it to
someone else
it was only back in the waiting room
where she learned she needed surgery it
seems like in every every part of the
health care system including like the er
they're just so maxed out
um that people aren't getting the help
that they need all provinces report
hospital wait times differently in
ontario the average wait time to see a
doctor has gone up from an hour and a
half to more than two hours in the last
year and while the provincial target to
admit patience is eight hours in ontario
the average right now is 20. we've been
sounding the alarm about the health care
system for a long time it's just right
now it's at a level of crisis i think
that we haven't seen where there's real
true risks to people's health by not
being able to access care the crisis
healthcare workers say may have gotten
worse during the pandemic but it started
long before in 2018 the job vacancy rate
in ontario hospitals was under four
percent today it's closer to nine
percent and no area is in more dire need
than nursing which has seen vacancies
increase from 5 to 13 percent truthfully
we're breaking down the entire system is
breaking down during a six-day stretch
this month over 15 000 bc health care
workers called in sick at least once
that's almost 10 percent of the entire
workforce
insiders who live and breathe healthcare
have been warning of an impending crisis
for years
canadians now have no choice but to
listen
microlight global news toronto
well the summer surge of covet 19 is
here cases are climbing in many regions
but this summer there are mixed messages
on how provinces and territories should
respond and as jamie maraca reports
living with covid means canadians face a
continued risk of infection
angelica cougini is spending her work
day in the backyard trying to steer
clear of her family while she recovers
from her fourth bout of coveted 19. i'm
definitely not scared of coven it's
obviously a nuisance while testing has
largely slowed wastewater data shows
cases are up pretty much across the
country that's in part thanks to
omicron's highly transmissible
subvariant ba-5 coupled with the removal
of most public health measures we should
still have been encouraging people to
continue wearing the mask when they're
in public this week ottawa's top doctor
expressed her concern and asked people
to reassess their behaviors including
wearing masks indoors and outdoors in
crowded spaces but last week ontario's
chief medical officer of health said the
province had no plans to bring back
restrictions a similar sentiment heard
in quebec despite the rise in
hospitalizations there we do not need to
reinforce
public health policies or mandatory
acting from
for the population in the u.s there have
been 90 million reported coven 19 cases
since the pandemic began and in the last
two weeks infections have risen roughly
16 percent statistics prompting cities
like los angeles to consider
re-implementing indoor mask mandates in
san diego masking is now a requirement
for summer school while new york's
governor is holding off for now but i'm
going to reserve the right
to return this policy if the the numbers
change but waiting until cases explode
defeats the purpose says this public
health expert who worries leaving it up
to choice won't work if you don't
actually put something in place and and
in indicate to people and really sell
the message then you're not going to get
anywhere despite her reinfections kugini
who is fully vaccinated says she would
be happy to never wear a mask again i
think it's so much better the way that
we're doing it right now i think
definitely moving forward and living
with the virus is important the path
public health officials have now put us
on
for better or for worse jamie morocco
global news toronto
despite kovitz surging more canadians
are traveling again but those hoping to
breeze through airports and land borders
this summer are faced with growing
challenges and one program designed to
speed up service for trusted travelers
is still in limbo
nexus enrollment centers in canada have
not reopened since the beginning of the
pandemic despite american centers
opening their doors three months ago
shawn o'shea finds out why
the sign has read closed for more than
two years nexus enrollment centers like
the one here at toronto's pearson
international airport still shut down
and not available for all important
interviews
meaning that approved canadian trusted
travelers can't get their credentials to
allow them faster access to the us and
speedier return from international
destinations i think it's ridiculous you
know still closed and that delays
in processing those applications are
getting longer and longer we've reported
on this issue before two months ago
travelers we talked to were frustrated
at that delay my nexus expired during
the pandemic and i would like to try to
renew it american processing offices
reopened in april the canadian
government has said it's negotiating
with the united states on reopening ones
here because american border officers
make up part of the office staff now the
real issues come to light the americans
are balking at coming back because
border agents want to be able to carry
their sidearms inside the offices
something they're allowed to do at
border crossings and at pre-approval
points at canadian airports many of
these nexus offices are off-site they're
not at the airport locations any longer
so clearly the americans are
you know the consistency here in the
american position is not surprising
asked about the wrinkle the prime
minister in prince edward island said
this it's really important that we are
able to
stay true to our values as canadians but
justin trudeau wouldn't directly address
the sticking point american officers
carrying sidearms in nexus offices there
are ongoing conversations right now and
we're going to try and make sure they
get resolved in a way that is acceptable
to both sides standing on principle here
doesn't accomplish much because at the
end of the day pre-clearance is a
privilege it's not a rights this has
been overwhelmingly a positive thing for
canadian travelers and canadian trade
and so the biggest benefit here flows to
canada shawnee shea global news
for weeks now the world has been
watching cases of monkey pox rise and
today the world health organization
declared the outbreak a global health
emergency citing growing concern
especially for the lgbtq2 community our
reggie jacini reports
in a world exhausted after more than two
years of being caught up in a global
pandemic a rapidly spreading outbreak of
monkey pox has thrust yet another health
crisis under the spotlight who's
assessment is that the risk of monkey
pox is moderate globally with roughly 16
000 cases across 65 countries the world
health organization now deems this a
global health emergency recommending
against travel if experiencing symptoms
but it wasn't a unanimous decision nine
members were against the designation
since their the role of the committee is
to advise
the i
then had to act as a tie breaker i
consider this as a clause and no
consensus by them the number of cases
pales in comparison to that of covet 19
but experts say the risk is no less
serious it's weighted heavily in men who
have sex with men but not exclusively
two juvenile cases were discovered in
the u.s on friday still the medical
community is encouraging communication
be kept open and honest we've got to
alert that community and the physicians
who take care of them without
inducing
the terrible issue of stigma
across canada roughly 700 cases have
been reported and unlike covid vaccines
already exist but in far fewer
quantities
in toronto about 6 000 people have
received the jab so it wasn't really
even on my radar peter kelly a toronto
dancer was diagnosed in june after
noticing lesions on his body he's now
part of a medical study at toronto's st
michael's hospital i know that i wasn't
the only one i just kind of took the
plunge and
started to talk more openly about it
well this virus has ravaged parts of
western africa for decades its global
spread is worrisome the best way to
avoid this infection is to avoid being
exposed to it doctors welcome the
decision to declare this an emergency
arguing intervention before a disease
escalates is key
reggie chikini global news washington
coming up how the public now views the
canadian military after multiple
misconduct scandals within its ranks
not all canadians are confident the
military can appropriately deal with
serious allegations within its ranks
that's according to recent internal
national defense polling conducted after
multiple misconduct scandals and
concerns about racism and discrimination
morgan campbell reports
after months of disturbing revelations
involving senior members of the canadian
military the armed forces have been
forced to look inward and it appears the
canadian public has taken note of the
military's persistent systemic issues
concerning everything from alleged
sexual misconduct to inappropriate
behavior and racism within the ranks
some of them feel at odds with where the
culture has developed and and also
unsure that the current leadership is
able to sort of steer the institution in
the right direction the march 2022
report produced by consulting firm
earnscliff strategy group was
commissioned by d d to assess canadian
attitudes toward the military and found
that nearly 40 percent of canadians are
not confident the caf will appropriately
deal with allegations of sexual
misconduct while the canadian public
continues to hold generally favorable
views of the armed forces and the work
they do the report shows that support
isn't blind i'm not surprised
that the public perception right now
is the way it is because we see it
happen to flow with whatever is going on
and because the arbor report is fairly
recent
that scathing report authored by former
supreme court justice louise arbor
revealed a military culture that is rife
with sexual misconduct white nationalism
and racism it also questioned whether
cadets in the regular officer training
programs should attend civilian
universities instead of royal military
colleges which arbor says suffer from a
quote's continued prevalence of sexual
misconduct
preliminary figures from the department
of national defense show that the
proportion of women set to be admitted
to the program this year sits at just 18
percent far short of the five-year high
of 27 percent set last year simply
trying to adjust the numbers of men and
women who are going into these colleges
is going to really address those bigger
issues meanwhile dnd's polling also
found that women were less convinced
that the armed forces culture will
change in the future which could explain
the low enrollment numbers being
reported at canada's military colleges
morgan campbell global news toronto
a ferry that caught fire during a
sailing from nova scotia to prince
edward island friday morning forcing
everyone on board to abandon ship is
still burning and all weekend crossings
are canceled
[Music]
182 passengers and 18 crew on the
northumberland ferry were safely taken
to shore after the fire broke out before
the ship ran aground the fire has been
contained to the engine room and exhaust
funnels but firefighters ended on-board
efforts to extinguish the fire last
night out of an abundance of caution
passengers have been told their vehicles
may not be able to be recovered
keeves says russian rockets landed in
the ukrainian port city of odessa today
less than a day after the country signed
deals to allow the resumption of vital
grain exports in the region
several explosions were heard in the
area in an attack that ukrainian
officials are calling a spit in the face
of turkey and the united nations who
helped broker the new grain export
agreements just yesterday
ukraine says some of the port's
infrastructure was damaged but
preparations to restart exports from the
black sea ports are still continuing
[Applause]
countries across europe are buckling
under extreme heat
on the greek island of lesbos a popular
beachside resort has been evacuated
after a wildfire exploded in size
destroying nearby homes
strong winds are fanning already
towering flames as tourists and
residents flee in small boats and buses
last year greece suffered the country's
worst heat wave in 30 years and is now
facing another summer of raging
wildfires
ahead the resilience and resentment of
residential school survivors on the eve
of the pope's trip to canada
final preparations are underway with
just hours remaining until pope francis
touches down in alberta officials in
edmonton are warning residents of
upcoming road closures and significant
delays as thousands flock to take part
in the historic visit but further east
in quebec a first nations community is
voicing their concerns ahead of a trip
that some are calling unnecessary mike
armstrong has their story
[Music]
this community ghanawagi was the home of
the first indigenous person from north
america to be sainted by the catholic
church
kateri te kakuita was born in the 1650's
she was canonized in 2012. there's a
school named after her a park a hospital
she is remembered here also remembered
the dark chapter of the catholic church
that was residential schools
i don't think i'll ever
be able to let it go
ruth loft was taken from her family
every school year from the age of five
to 12. she still wears a cross around
her neck today but not without
resentment they took our language our
culture you know they even gave me a
number i was a number in there
my number was seven
the pope's apology this week for
residential schools loft says comes too
late
for me
i don't want to see him
he's not going to he's not going to
erase
what happened to me all the damage that
these schools did to me it's not going
to erase it it's still here with me
there are members of the community who
will make the trek to quebec city for
the visit but there may not be any
residential school survivors i'm
representing the mall council gonowagi
arnold boye is a member of the band
council he'll be attending his parents
are survivors and he's trying to get
them to go with him but other survivors
have decided the trip would be too long
and difficult at their age so they
backed out unfortunately but their
you know their families will be attended
now there are those who don't think
other members of the community should be
going or that the pope should be coming
they don't want an apology they say as
much as a confession and changes
show me what you're gonna do
show me how you're gonna help us make a
move don't come here and say oh
i'm sorry bless you my child you know
what that does nothing for me
the local school named after gonowagi's
saint was once a residential day school
run by the catholic church that is
something that has changed it's now run
by the community and teaches children
to embrace their mohawk heritage
mike armstrong global news montreal
next a childhood dream comes full circle
a vancouver man fulfills his career wish
more than 150 000 people flooded the
streets of berlin today for one of the
world's largest pride parades it's
christopher street day in germany which
commemorates the riots that broke out in
new york in 1969
after police raided a gay bar
it has been celebrated in germany since
1979. the theme for this year's parade
is united in love
the vancouver police department
introduced its newest team member in a
unique way our camera crew captured the
surprise announcement this week which
was 13 years in the making catherine
ercart explains
it was 2009 when we told you about amman
joanna who used to be a little bit
scared of police yeah i was a little bit
because i thought that because i used to
be scared because some of my parents
used to tell me
if you like stare at the police a lot
and you're like walking around them and
looking all suspicious that you're gonna
get caught and they're gonna take you
then the ten-year-old and his brother
constructed a police vehicle and gifted
it to officer terry parmar and his
partner we have two police people here
one's a lady one's a guy
and the guy the lady is driving the guy
as a passenger
and we
put a little bit of details in here that
interaction prompted amman's interest in
policing and the two stayed in touch
and then just come over here fast
forward 13 years and 23 year old iman
just received news he'd been hoping for
from his longtime mentor tell you
something okay i know you've worked
really hard for this yeah for the past i
don't know how long it's been but we're
gonna hire you
it's been a goal of mine since i was
very young
probably since
nine or eight or nine years old when i
met terry the first time
amman's new job with vpd
special municipal constable let me be
the first executive member to give you
one of our vpd challenge coins thank you
so much and
really proud thank you that you're
joining our organization and you're
going to continue that mentorship for
other generations this freshly hired
officer was always clear about wanting
to be on the right side of the law good
guys because they do good things a
little boy's positive brush with the law
many years ago for us my brother and i
just to kind of see that the police
aren't the bad guys and they're actually
very nice and they won't arrest us just
for showing up and you know talking to
them all right right
a driving force behind his choice to
pursue a career in policing
catherine cart global news
and that is global national for this
saturday night i'm tracy tong tonight's
your canada is the signal hill national
historic site in st john's newfoundland
and labrador thanks for watching hope
you can join us again tomorrow have a
great night
[Music]
you